all right we're live live
hello
hello all right hello everybody let me
give you some context uh we are very
excited to be here uh for a lot of you
you know that um
we've
been deep in the nft world vayner nft a
company i started several months ago
uh
landed a great client in budweiser we've
been strategizing around the genre of
music
mike boyd who's on this screen as many
of you found out through a very viral
tick tock video has been my plug in my
ear for 13 years which is why i always
seem way more up on [ __ ] than people
think i could be
and uh
and him and i and avery and many others
have been working on this project we're
incredibly first and foremost thank you
budweiser for allowing us to see this
vision through that we believe in so so
so much
before i let mike kind of frame this up
let me just say what's up to a bunch of
people gerald i see you on facebook carl
i see you jennifer we see you on youtube
um carly limbo on facebook so keep the
questions coming but i'm going to set up
the macro context and let mike uh take
over
these brilliant faces that you're seeing
are artists and music that mike and i
genuinely in our soul believe are next
and what do we mean by our next they've
all achieved
a lot more than most musicians achieve
it ever
when they start out on i'm going to be
an artist
but when we say what who's next we're
talking about the video that you can
find on youtube right now where i'm
sitting with gunna in 2018 and our
belief is like you're gonna really be
known not
you're very well known and everybody
here is so young in their journey
but we believe have incredible upside
when we think about collectibility in
the nft world and this nft project
you know i grew up in this game i think
in rookie cards
i think in rookie cards and i think nfts
are going to take and create rookie
cards
out of things that we've historically
not had we've had rookie cards in sports
but have we had rookie cards and music
the answer is no nfps are going to
create it and many of the faces that you
see today through this project that we
just did with budweiser
have now established their rookie cards
and i'm excited about that i'm excited
to see them continue to shine and watch
those rookie cards do their thing so
mike what do you want to add to this
well yeah i mean you're the man but all
these artists right here they're so
excited they're all over the world so
for everyone watching
we're going to bring in artists from all
over the world all different time zones
and everyone has their own question
and all the questions are pretty similar
we we have to talk nfts we have to talk
how they're affecting the music industry
you can see millie has that plaque
behind her
farina's coming live from medellin in
south america lulu is in mexico leo's in
l.a
we have time and sporty in new york
helena's in miami she's going to help
translate anything if needed but farina
wants to talk about nft's music industry
but how it relates to the latin world
you know south america like what are you
seeing in that world right now
marina
hola
[Music]
she wants to know gary how you think
that nfts might change uh the music
world in the next few years the next 10
years
i mean look i've been already famously
and elena when you're off if you can go
on mute because the background noise
thank you
um
i think that
it's going to profoundly change it
the blockchain the consumer blockchain
is a ledger
that is more effective as a piece of
technology to distribute
than anything we have in publishing
it's also a fund-raising mechanism
when you think about why artists have
gone and signed record deals
there are many reasons
but
let there be no confusion
the biggest reason has been the upfront
bag that they give you that lets you
kind of settle into your life
and then you become partners with that
public you know record label and
depending on the leverage you have and
how much heat you have you're gonna have
different deals
i do believe that the blockchain will
create an inevitable world where instead
of record labels being your majority
partner
your fans will become your minority
partner in your master's in your career
it's profound it's gonna take time
and oh by the way
there's a lot of good record labels that
really do do a good job with marketing
that do help you get your tour proper so
you're going to have to see the
evolution of music managers evolve into
different things
but this is going to change book
publishing movie fundraising the rec the
music industry
it's a big deal i think it's going to
change it as much as the internet
changed
the music industry the consumer
blockchain that's what this is this is
about the blockchain getting
consumerized to the masses
the consumer blockchain is about to
change the world and
music
is one of the most universal things in
our society
and obviously it will be changed with it
thank you of course thank you
hell yeah there's a lot of comments
going crazy right now on the
chat about that farina okay and then
millie has an important question that's
been on top of different people's
conversations about women getting more
involved in general i know there's some
organizations that have that focus like
what are your thoughts on that gary
i mean look
mike you've known me for 13 years you
know longer even
my mother wasn't able to go to college
in the ussr because she was jewish
right i grew up in very diverse
neighborhoods and a very diverse
you know my the first 18 years of my
life my first 22 years of my life were
uncomfortably diverse meaning the
greatest thing that ever happened to me
i didn't even know about
thoughts of anything else i just had
everything around me and so i always
care about this stuff and you know i'm
actually very proud of what we're seeing
you know world of women
let there be no confusion world of women
is a top five project in the entire
space
you know how epic that is
right um
i i think that
diversity and inclusion makes everything
better and i think web 3 has no
gatekeepers this is something people
don't understand the blockchain
nobody owns it
it's these are servers that are
decentralized so unlike the remember how
everybody in here and everybody in the
world is hot about the algorithm you're
hot
[ __ ] facebook [ __ ] script tick tock's
not putting me on nft land is
there is nothing it's you and your
audience
and whether you're black brown pink
orange boy girl alien
this time you've got nobody to blame
decentralized
if you're not popping that's you that's
your fault that's your fault leo
and so i'm very excited but i do think
beacons of the industry you know you
know this mike i have been purposely and
thoughtfully doing extra homework
six seven nine months ago on female-led
projects because i because i because i
because i want to pull people up my
mom's my hero she's a girl she's my
[ __ ] hero so that's what i want to do
and somebody else might want to do it
for native americans or the indigenous
people or white dudes do you or by the
way i want to pull up jets fans if
you're a jets fan up here dm me i will
support your project more like people
but it's exciting and i think there's a
lot of good very
healthy combos around this and i i see a
lot of good stuff brewing
listen
i'm gonna go macro on everybody the
world is the world
you you either choose to see the good
[ __ ] that's going on or the bad shit's
going on i'm just gonna make it real
real honest for everybody
the more you try to see the good [ __ ]
the happier it's gonna work for you
and so what all we can do is all do our
thing and do the best we can and i've
seen a lot of good stuff on that and
it's a great question and we're seeing
i'm seeing a lot there are fema mumba
sarah bauman there are there's a lot of
good [ __ ] going on so i'm excited hell
yeah thank you gary for answering the
question of course millie
congratulations it's what actually one
of the things i wanted to do here it
doesn't need to be just a q a nft talk
one of the things i really want to do
and i know that the project pre-minted
so i know this is kind of already
selling out or sold out i gotta try to
dm while i ask millie to do this we need
to spend a minute maybe we go back to
fadina with elena like
i want everybody who's watching to know
why you and i might think these people
are about to be superstars and why it's
good for them to get their rookie card
somebody just minted a milli rookie card
but somebody else watching might want to
go to open sea and buy that [ __ ] milly
why don't you tell everybody what's been
happening here for the last couple of
minutes because things are starting to
pop off yeah i think um
you know uh it's been a really exciting
time doing this project and i think
actually what's really impressed me
about the project you know irrespective
of the relationships we've all made
together as artists but one of the
things that's so exciting to me about it
is i think
it's like you just said other kind of
mediums have been very gatekeepery
particularly for independent artists i
might add and you know we don't know
everything about nfts nor i'm sure to
people that know a lot more than i do
but just that platform of discord and
the budweiser discord the conversations
that have been going on
it's just been such a welcoming space um
for somebody like me who's really just
starting their career in music but to
have people in those conversations so
willing to answer your questions and you
know i asked the question the discord
actually about women and nfts and the
response i got about oh you can go over
here and read this article and you know
i think it's just been
it's been a very pleasant surprise how
open and positive everybody has been
that's within that world welcoming us as
artists into it
two things one millie just said
something that i'm so fired up about
mike
when two of these wonderful people
collab with each other that meant
through this project i need to know
right away because i'm crazy on that
song that's number one
number two
uh for everybody who's watching the open
mint for the royals starts at 3 p.m if
people can share in the comments the
link avery i know you're in there maybe
you can do that the pre-mint white list
has been open since 12 30. if you bought
a bug can heritage you get one for free
if you were part of some other
communities you were whitelisted so
we're opening up fully at three which is
an hour and 15 minutes just to give
people uh some info to that the bud
discord has a lot going on uh avery's on
youtube right now i just see her comment
maybe she'll share that link i see
ghosts looking for the link if people
can share that link uh that's we can get
this going on might keep us moving oh
yeah yeah so quickly because we're gonna
bring more people in we have time and
sporty in new york they're both bringing
the new wave we have lulu in mexico her
singing her tick tock is crazy leo he's
super artsy and he's he's actually with
doji all the time gary by the way she
might even be in the background right
there i mean that's my fiance i don't
think i can get rid of her
you know what i think about your girl i
i she you listen she's crazy i think
she's
superstar superstar let's open up the
mics because mike when are we bringing
one more minute or a couple more minutes
let's let's let anybody here who wanted
to say what's up or something let's give
them three four minutes fire away
anybody have something to say
gary
how do you think nfts are going to
affect live
shows i think they will become the
tickets to live shows and then become
collector bulls i believe long-term leo
you will do shows
where your ticket is an nft
you obviously you know this all of you
know this your shows start as like nine
people
and then if everything goes right they
become 50 000 right
those nft tickets from your ninth
nine people shows
become collectibles if you become
[ __ ] polo g if you become kanye if
you be right so
but check this this is crazy [ __ ] so now
you did a show for 80 people in a little
club in atlanta and the way you got in
was not a piece of paper or a qr code or
a [ __ ] [ __ ] email confirmation
it's a [ __ ] nft yeah you got the nft
it stands to win right yeah now check
this you put a 10 royalty
on that nft ticket that if it ever sells
in the future
you go on and become [ __ ] future yeah
buying that [ __ ] collectible for a
thousand a piece and you're making a
hundred bucks
passive
on some royalty [ __ ] it's [ __ ] crazy
i'd love to hear it really
you think that the blockchain is doing
is the person that is the artist and
creator
and the audience
keep the economics not all the stuff in
the middle yeah it cuts out the
middleman correct but
every artist loves hearing that
don't get too high in your own supply if
you aren't able to build an audience
without a middle man or woman you're
gonna have people in your pockets
yeah and you should because guess what
sixty percent
of a hundred million is a lot better
than a hundred percent of forty thousand
okay since since we're moving into this
more decentralized space and the music
and everything is becoming more
exclusive um with crypto and with nfts
do you think it's going to be possible
for artists to release their albums or
their playlists in like nft form without
multiple people owning it and you kind
of
know you're where you're um where all of
your stuff is going if i
had musical talent the answer would be
yes
the question is do you all have
marketing talent
absolutely yes my dude absolutely what
what people don't understand is we love
to [ __ ] on a label but what about when
the label put that billboard up in la
what about like like but but i think the
role of the manager
and the label and the agent and the
marketing company is all gonna get
mushed up
like this is why i spent 14 years
building a marketing [ __ ] death star
because i think the only thing that's
going to matter with technology is can
you make [ __ ] happen
and i know if me and mike and everybody
always jokes about it but if me and mike
really went there and said [ __ ] it
vayner records here's what we do for a
far less percentage we're just going to
make you pop off and that's how we share
i have a funny feeling we're going to
sign the [ __ ] out of people
that's oh yeah yo we got to bring in the
next batch right something crazy
what's great everybody
thank you
[Music]
all right i'm excited hell yeah yeah
we'll just have more open open mics yep
here i come everybody we see you where
do i apply for vayner records i see you
left eye right eye
um
listen one more time before we get these
in this is an nft project rookie cards
of up and coming artists that we really
believe in uh
it's right now on the budweiser discord
um it's really really really interesting
the open mind starts in an hour and 12
minutes um we're really really excited
about it
hell yeah yeah i'm telling seth bring
him on in i know we got fresco trey back
there there he is pow-pow
oh you're on mute
hey
what's going on
how are you doing
how about you you coming in live from
miami or what
no i'm from i'm in medellin
um everyone here is super excited about
nfts and congrats fresco for getting
that song in the nba game bro
let's go fresco did i not tell you to
[ __ ] with us on that now what
one more time at 3 30 because i got
pushed by 30 minutes at 3 30 for
everybody who's looking budweiser
royalty oh there we go good job finally
here's the url
this is the project we just have the
first group in here here's the second
group these are all artists that mike
boyd and i are co-signing believing
these are future superstars
even since all these people were first
put on my radar either i found them on
instagram or tic toc or 90 of time mike
sent them to me
all of them have already had more heat
than the first second we've seen them
but the heat that we're talking about
for all these people is all your friends
know who they are and that's why we
think they're next a lot of people that
[ __ ] with music know who these people
are but i'm talking everybody and so
that's what we see for a lot of these
artists in the next two three years
that's why we chose them for this
incredible project
called budweiser royalty uh nfts it
opens at 3 30. the url is here uh we did
a white list for people in certain
communities or the people that bought
the first budweiser nft those people get
to get one of these for free but it is
the rookie cards from this incredible
crew and i'm gonna let mike kind of give
a little con mike why don't you do the
mike boyd rapid fire who who everybody
in the screen is where they're from and
like one little nugget you want to say
about them because mike boyd's always
got a fresh nugget oh yeah thank you so
samantha sanchez satoma they're both
amazing on tick tock if you're not
following him follow him asap uh
samantha's from spain but she's in miami
so tomo's out in l.a fresco trey's in la
but he's you know memphis king there pao
pao she just said she's a medellin she's
normally in miami she's with uh rich
music and such and all them the whole
crew there anymore is coming live from
mexico her music is crazy so she's all
over the playlist and then
our guy polo t the legend the new yorker
holding down the city yes sir yes sir
nice to meet everybody
let's let the ladies talk first let's be
gentlemen up in here uh ladies any
anything to say about your music about
nfts about this project this is open
forum for you for anything you have to
say will be beautiful
well i'm so excited i'm so excited to be
here thank you for this opportunity i
can't believe we're doing something with
bob weiser i'm like i can't still
believe it i'm like i go to target and
i'm like okay like you want me
but really cool thank you for having me
here and nice meeting you all you guys
look so cool i have amazing music and i
can't wait to hear it
yeah yeah thank you as well for having
us on oh sorry
um
thank you thank you yeah i was just
gonna say thank you for having us on
here and giving us opportunity and it's
giving us a chance to learn more about
nfts i had like no idea about them
beforehand really so it's cool
has it been a fun education for you of
101 yeah it's
it has been really cool to learn about
it and just kind of see what i can do
with it and the potential and then
potentially myself with it which is
really cool so yeah it's awesome i'm
very excited
love it
i just want to say thank you for having
me as well like i was actually looking
for what you have done garyvee like i
was being ringing and just listening to
your talks and i found them very
educational in so many ways um
for me as a musician obviously working
with other emerging artists is such a
great opportunity i'm just connecting
with you guys all i feel like it's i
don't know it's such a different a big
world out there and nfts is something
that i've been hearing a lot this year
like i could see it everywhere but i
didn't understand fully what it meant
and after this partnership like of
course there's something i'm emerging
myself in and you'll stay blessed for
having me
very nice she's going to our mexico city
office soon i know
no i'm like starting off just saying
thank you it's crazy like i've always
i've been hearing about it for a long
time and it's always like a really
confusing thing and i used to be in the
business but then
you think you know it all and then
something new appears you know and it's
like a completely new thing it's a
completely new world that i'm super
excited and i was like i have to learn
about this but then you like i don't
know you have no time to do it but then
you're for like for the with this
project i was like
technology yeah technology doesn't care
what we're up to it's going to do new
[ __ ]
it doesn't waste
it doesn't wait so if you don't do it
like you're gonna like you're gonna get
stuck behind so it was like so after
like being involved in the project i was
going in for hours just like researching
everything and seeing the potential and
it's funny because like it's an honor to
be here because you put nfts and your
name is the only thing that pops up
which is a great thing no but it's crazy
and it's over here you know and it's
it's a new world completely and i like
i'm starting to see the potential that i
can have in the future and it's insane
so i'm super pumped
hey elon hi mike
what's good
i'm good how are you good we're just
asking the ladies first and we'll get to
t and trey like how tell us a little
something about
well first of all since we didn't get to
introduce you where are you based out of
and let us know how this project's been
going for you how are you learning about
nfts or the music or just some of your
vibes
i'm i live in new york i'm currently in
l.a
um
the second question was how was this
process yeah like are you like with nfts
like was like did you know anything has
been interesting to learn like what's
this process been like for you
well i'm a nerd so all of my
all of my friends are into nfts and i've
always asked them questions about it and
they're like you're an artist you stay
in your world
but
i look up youtube videos and whatnot and
it's just i think this is there's a
surge it's like an artistic renaissance
that's happening right now whether you
view it i still have a lot of learning
to do but whether you view it as a good
thing or a bad thing because of the
entry level so low
um there's a value in it specifically
for all of us being artists because um
especially if you're indie you know i'm
not india anymore but um
you know it's something that
you know if you drop an nft and you have
a good niche audience or enough fans
um you can provide utility and you can
give them access to certain things such
as
um
vip
tickets to a festival which a lot of
fans you know i did my first festival at
day in vegas and a lot of people
loved festivals but now imagine getting
a vip access
or a selfie or five seconds virtually on
film it's right limited edition hoodie
like it's what you can do and it's just
it's beyond the art and i think that's
what's most exciting for me is that
i can give access to people who really a
believe in me and find value in it so i
love it it's awesome
polo team what you got to say for
yourself man it's been just a journey in
general like you know i was saying for
the job like
this whole this whole project just even
like right before this project you know
honestly i was preparing knowing that
like you know i'm saying we were about
to move on this just you know talking
with mike talking with you specifically
and uh
it's just been crazy just just seeing so
much like just seeing how fast one this
is rapidly growing this this is crazy
two
the the the height you can be in your
career and work at nft is you can be in
the beginning you could be at the end of
your career you could be in the middle
of your career so it's like somebody
like like what
he had just said like you know i'm
saying i'm independent so somebody like
me this is something that i could have
throughout my whole entire life with my
fan base with my people who stream or
matter of fact people who like you know
i'm saying hey let's just see what this
kid is about you know what i mean like
this is this is literally like what what
we need if i had this as a kid to invest
into the bands i loved or to the rappers
i loved or it would have been crazy mike
boyd would be a billionaire if this [ __ ]
was around independent youtubers too
like
mike boyd mac miller wiz khalifa nicki
minaj these people had less than 10 000
followers and mike boyd was bringing
them to me might be a billionaire it's
[ __ ] this is crazy and we've been
doing this for a long time but i'm glad
that i'm proud of y'all
i'm glad that you know what i'm saying
i'm being brought in by you guys you
know what i'm saying makes me feel much
safer and also this is just like a whole
refresh moment in life where it's like
you know i'm saying this is the new
school like
and we're at the top of our class
everybody in this in this live stream
right now we're at the top of our
classes being here and you know
investing the time into actually
learning and stuff like so you know what
i'm saying this is just second time
around being a cool kid
yeah we need all you guys to collab i
know gary hinted at it but your your
sounds are all so crazy and you're from
all over the world and if you all made a
song together it would go nuts trey
let's see if we can get trey in here
just talk a little ladder trick
oh mutant go ahead trey
you're still on mute
there he goes go ahead trey
no we completely lost you
oh man
all right while trey's trying to figure
that [ __ ] out let me just recap because
there's a lot of people coming into the
stream i can see
these incredible young artists are part
of a project that uh we at vayner nft
put together
uh with our client budweiser called
budweiser royalty
it's a project that is
nfts for all these individual different
rarity scales
we thought of them as
a
rookie card to these artists uh there'll
be a lot more things we do with
budweiser with people that hold these
but
you know when people say well what's the
utility what does it get me sometimes
it's just a collectible
you know
oh there we go trey go ahead
trey do i sound i sound better now you
sound delicious
you're good
good go ahead man
now basically i was going to say i want
to start off with i'm grateful for the
opportunity you know what i'm saying i
got a big thanks to you know everybody i
mean big love for everybody i'm hearing
what they do um
this is my first nft experience so being
able to just bring it in with mike and
gary y'all just giving me game and just
you know so walking me through it is
just you know i'm super grateful for
that and
i'm just excited on the possibilities of
the whole nft space you know i've been
doing a little research myself and it's
just crazy that the amount of
opportunities can be uh that are
presented with nft so
we remiss to not talk about what's going
on with draftking
right you know just a little bit of that
experience of what it feels like to be
in this 2k
said it one more time
just just a quick second i mean we'd be
crazy not to mention this very big
watershed moment for you of having your
song in 2k
tease pull the perks over there giving
some love like you just got your song
selected to 2k
let's let's i mean nobody who pays
attention to music is confused that's a
real look how do you feel
uh it's crazy because um just going into
creating the whole song i remember when
we had our um
our zoo our zoom meeting about the song
lose his brain so my ideas not
everything just clicked so i feel like
even with it being in draftkings like
you said you told me everything it just
clicked and it just feels so normal and
like i feel like it's supposed to happen
because
me making a song i'm not the whole time
i'm thinking like let me try to make it
to where like
i can add nba players i can add
basketball references and then 2k picked
it up it's just like that's like it was
kind of like a sign from god or
something because i went into my mindset
making it was already on that tip not
it wasn't i didn't make it trying to say
all right i want to get into k i just
made it trying to
make a song about jacksonville that's
why i get it again yeah
for them to pick it up like that it was
crazy it was just like dang
it it all came full circle
mike where are we with timing any other
artists i want to make sure logistically
we're good how are we feeling we're
perfect so seth is back there he's going
to start pulling people in now
ciao thank you
except for elon she's going to stay for
a second okay
thank you everybody else we love you
thank you
thank you thank you thank you so much
you're welcome samantha
really fun so much fun yeah so
everyone's going to join
um seth is figuring out so elon real
quick i know you were saying you're a
nerd about this stuff i know everyone in
the discord has been checking out your
music gary she graduated from ivy league
college in three years i know
that's kind of rare
i mean look that she's we've known she
was smart maybe the masses don't but we
i knew her nerd life i mean you don't
get to accomplish that
uh just skip it along trust me i tried
there's no way of getting into those
places so emma is is
the thought of like what this can mean
for the seven seven-year-old you right
because once this really gets at scale
it's gonna be huge for artists has that
run through your mind of like oh my god
in 15 years when every like real people
can really just go to their audience and
play that independence round out
completely because now you can be
discovered on soundcloud spotify
tick-tock all that discovery that used
to be impossible you needed mtv you
needed places players and now we have
the technology infrastructure for the
economics to be distributed in a
different way pretty pretty wild yeah
it's really exciting i feel like
the younger version of me if i saw if
enough tea is being available and like
you can get a facetime call or something
like that with your favorite artist
like when i was younger i wouldn't go to
the park i would watch interviews
because i was obsessed with music so i
was just like how the [ __ ] do you like
become this thing like become this
artist you know there's no all of my
friends are in medical school right now
and yeah it's difficult but it's a clear
path right so to me i would be out here
just like mike purchasing these nfts and
like trying to like submerse like be in
this world with my favorite artists and
try to learn and
i don't know i just want to take time to
like thank both you gary and mike
because you all believed in me when i
had like 2k followers i remember i
performed with small whack at your
holiday party and i'm like
how the [ __ ] did mike and gary find me
but it's just like we dig
we dig we love people we love music
and we love doing the homework and we
believe in our intuition yeah
all right mike let's introduce these
incredible things yeah elon we'll see
you soon oh and elon knows cabelito i'm
pretty sure right all right
all right cool so yeah everyone's from
all over the map here again but cabalito
how much time did you spend in minnesota
by the way because we're doing v con
like 10 years that's where i like
studied music where i went to school
yeah that's where i moved to like i
lived in new york in the bronx and then
elizabeth new jersey and then eventually
migrated to minnesota where i like went
to school for music and high school
mike let's do that let's do the thing
that you did because it's good for the
audience couple things you'll see this
the mint that has all of these
incredible artists rookie nfts is
scrolling below you it opens up at 330
us.
nft that's what we're talking about
we're talking about these fresh faces
budweiser royalty artists that mike and
i and budweiser genuinely believe are
next they've all already done their
thing when we say next we mean all of
your friends will know who they are
and uh and we're here kind of talking to
them about their music and about nfts
mike if you can kind of go around the
horn again say who the artist is say
where they're from and maybe a little
nugget of
why you first initially got high
oh yeah all right cool so adrian here
put me on the bain house bain house is
in uh mexico and adrian's gonna help
translate but adrian and bain house they
work together on the music and then
leanne here she actually spent time in
jersey she's in spain and she's doing
live shows all over spain really happy
to see you taking off and then blue we
all know blue she just did saturday
night live she brings
features yeah
and then blue she i mean
we put her in a pepsi campaign in the
past like
we love you blue everyone loves you guys
and then cap little here obviously if
anyone watches gary's youtube we had her
in the office we had a cool meeting we
believed in her for so long and her her
tick tock's going up she's good at
tick-tock and then nardine here we just
did the craziest song with nardine for
vaynermedia she's in australia we worked
around the clock through the time zones
and she killed it and so she's popping
off in australia we're so happy this is
the farthest time zone on the call
what's up i love it
let's go back around the horn one mike
so why don't we start with you
how's this process been learning about
nfts and or what's going on with music
and or how crazy was it was snl like
anything you want to talk about
um yeah i mean martial artist was like
shout out mike and gary you guys are
legends thanks for always um bringing
the opportunities through i really
really appreciate the support
um yeah i mean i've been i've been
interested in nfts for a while now and i
think this was
you know the perfect just such a cool
way in um especially with you gary since
you're like
you know you're the king of it and i've
started learning a lot about it just
through following you and just watching
your content about it
um
so and i have a bunch of friends who are
involved and a lot of people on my on my
management team are really into it and
this is just a really cool way to to get
involved
and you know there's obviously tons of
possibilities and opportunities so i
think it's
it's just really really exciting to be a
part of and i'd rather you know be in it
now than have to
you know catch up with me
i love that like be the example then
follow the example later on so i think
it's really cool that we're all involved
in this
i love it mike keep passing us around
while i read the comments and try to
bring some value to them all right cool
i know nardine has a lot of thoughts
she's been in the discord so nardine
what's on top of your mind
what's up hi
yeah shout out my gary this is so cool
um i started when i first found out what
nfts are about a year ago or maybe a
year and a half ago i was like listening
to your podcast story and so this is
just like such a crazy full circle like
whoa i'm here and i'm doing it with
budweiser so yeah thanks so much for
having me
um it looks like what i'm really curious
about is like aside from
um because i've been gone in like really
researching and like even thinking about
learning how to code because i'm just so
fascinated by it um but what i'm really
interested in is like aside from merch
and collectibles and um
nfts that fans can buy i'm really
interested in how nfts or like smart
contracts and blockchain can actually
change
kind of the back end of the music
industry if that makes sense so like
streaming
i mean do you know how much easier it is
when three of you collaborate to
distribute the royalties when the
nft is doing the work
yeah exactly yeah
it's gonna change the whole world i'm
reading all these comments nfts are
scams this is stupid and i'm laughing
because in 1995
when i talked about launching wine
library.com
everybody told me the internet was a fad
and a scam and a waste of time and then
in 2005 when i was like myspace
friendster youtube twitter when mike
boyd joined vaynermedia day one
everybody thought it was a scam a waste
of time who gives a [ __ ] about twitter
youtube stupid like people hate on what
they don't understand yeah people are
scared to put in the work everybody who
drop some scam there you all are [ __ ]
scared to put in the work what about
that and so i love when the future comes
now
let everybody understand when they buy
an nft with all of you on here
with this nft
this is a collectible
so if you all don't go on to become
super duper famous and then people want
to collect it well then that won't
return money
that's where the collectible work but
that's how always collectibles work one
of the cards you bought in 1986 was
michael jordan and it went to 600 000
and another one was sleepy floyd and
that went to a dollar like everything is
predicated on y'all
collectible but
if budweiser and us decide a strategy
that we want to turn
all these entities with y'all into
something else later we just add that to
the smart contract
it's different it's real different and
so it's really fun to see the world
evolve you see a lot of people get it
the problem is when people see the new
big thing there's a lot of scams and a
lot of bad things and like 99 of the
nfts that are coming out right now are
going to zero going to zero there's so
much bad behavior influencer pumping
[ __ ] people thinking of tons but
that's what happened on the internet all
those internet stocks in six seven eight
they went to zero but the macro it's
game changing
and yo cavalito she wanted to ask about
what you think about this collection
right here gary and catalina you could
add to it whatever you want but that's
the main thought right
yeah that means the question that i that
i had was like how do you like what do
you think the future of this specific
collection is
to like let fires no like
i think it's a high-risk high reward
investment
you know me and mike
look at
so many goddamn artists it's not even
funny
and
we
you guys all know this about us
we're not a record label we're not
trying to sign you we're not trying to
get in your pockets we are trying to put
karma into something we both love
and we work on it and work on it and we
make a bet on people and we support them
and let the karma points rack up right
but
me and mike were right about gunna me
and mike were right about sweetie me and
mike have been wrong i'm not gonna call
out those names because that's not nice
we've been wrong and so i think
you know these are positioned as rookie
cards i really think rookie nfts for
music artists is going to be a thing in
the future
and just in the sports card world
sometimes it's tops sometimes it's the
meaning sometimes it's done by a food
company like back in the days in the 50s
like
cons
hot dogs made the first jerry west card
which is the guy who's the logo of the
nba it's worth a lot of money this is a
brand budweiser is making rookie cards
and you know my intuition is that many
of you in this collection have a real
shot like a real shot
and uh and that's where the chips will
fall out but also what's cool is if in
three years let's say god forbid
okay god forbid
none of you went crazy let's just say
goddammit didn't create
what's good you late bro
bro
fair
so
you know
i mean that was actually perfect timing
with keid
is on a different level as a lot of us
know already he's taken more steps when
we first started [ __ ] with keid
he was really early in his journey
he's in a different step if we did this
with keith three years ago
and that that rookie nft today would be
worth more because keith's got a lot of
fans that want to have that just like
there's fans of michael jordan and
lebron james and kevin durant and mario
lemieux well and so that's the [ __ ] that
i'm really
really intrigued by with this collection
but again finish that thought because i
got bounced off if god forbid we don't
like how everything goes in six years
budweiser could say we're doing this
again and everybody who's got a royalty
from back in 2022 you can get a free one
of the 200 that's what's crazy about
nfts you're never out of it
you can always add value to the nft and
that's going to be wild to watch over
the years exactly
keith we'll talk to you in a second here
we're going to talk to everyone else
real quick real fast yo leanne so what's
up in spain like what are you thinking
about right now
great i mean in the us everything goes
faster in spain we like a little bit
slowly but like lately maybe the past
four months producers from spain are
also releasing nfts so that's crazy i
mean
they're doing like
photo game
and dropping like
um
drawings with their face
producers face artists face so
it's growing a little bit but not like
not as fast as in the us you know so i'm
very excited that i'm here with you guys
oh yeah and adrian bain has you got a
quick thought
yeah i mean for us in mexico too like uh
things are just starting to pop off
actually like a lot of people start to
build up like um mining
um big
uh
like you know like [ __ ]
bodegas or whatever where they are
starting to mining and [ __ ] and a lot of
investors like monterrey where even
i are from it's an industrial city but
now for us it's been crazy because um
you know it's it's a great city
culturally talking like no one it was
that into like art or whatever but now
that all these
industry like industrial people started
to like
get interest on money on like nfps
cryptos and whatever
they seem to be like super interested on
artists now so
for us it's it seems to be
um going to the right direction you know
for especially you know like in slowly
we're supporting a lot of upcoming and
new artists that come from from nothing
and having all these like millionaires
of people with money interested in
investing on new talent because of uh
what just gary said like um you know
putting putting the investment on on
rookies
that you know that are gonna become
something because
most of these like
um
industrial directors or whatever
they get
investment you know they get
they they understand that you have to
invest something and wait and be
peaceful
like peaceful you know like uh patient
and whatever to to get to somewhere and
now that they are understanding this
through art
and and music and
whatever it it those around enemies it's
it's crazy it's just i i've been getting
calls all this month after lulu and
benjaz like started talking about the
nfd's with you guys like everyone in
monterrey is excited about this new
chapter on the art scene so so yeah it's
groundbreaking for
for
[Music]
all right thank you guys thank you thank
you thank you
guys
[Music]
he's going to stay yeah
pete let's talk now man what's up what's
up
when's the new apple dropping bro that's
what they want to know
in a couple months right literally
oh
keith you're feeling good you feeling
mentally strong you ready to take that
next step yeah what's up gary it's good
to see you now man what's up
i miss you man you good bro yes man just
working on this album make sure it's the
great better work
dude that mike doesn't know i got
several trips to atlanta coming up so
i'm like we got some we got some trips
my man i'm in l.a i'm in liquidity
well there i'm off you can be in la for
super bowl yeah but
yeah beautiful all right we've got some
moments coming in a couple things to
remind people one with this drop of
three 30 gas is included so that's
exciting too a lot of the artists that
you're seeing come through here are
going to be performing at v-con and
other things we're going to be doing
with some of the others so
i see some more people coming in mike
maybe you can introduce our homies
hell yeah yeah so we have d the flyest
up here in boston can you all hear me
hell yeah we can hear you
and then we have beans we have beans
here she's out how are you doing
are you in l.a right now
i'm in vegas right now you're in vegas
all right yeah we love you
you are crazy i love your shippings for
real i appreciate you i appreciate you
it's great to meet you gary yeah of
course
hell yeah
and then we have phase yoda johnny in a
minute but yeah i mean key do the flies
beans if you all don't know each other
you need to get to know each other but
yeah let's talk nfts beans made a whole
freestyle on it
yeah i did a little you know a little
something
nice
like a little eight bars
it means what uh when you first heard
about nfts were you just like what the
[ __ ] is this or were you excited like
how to break down for you
honestly like i didn't have any idea
about it until we got into it um i feel
like i know a lot more about it now yeah
um but it's definitely a process i feel
like once i get like the actual nfts
from budweiser i'll i'll understand it
more because i'll actually have one you
know versus like just being in discord
or something like that but the discord
is cool as hell like the bad random
people in there some people just talk
[ __ ] but
it's it it's definitely like a lot of
information you could get in there so
i love it
flash looks good
yo d can you hear us i can't hear
nothing that's going on right there
gary i can't hear nobody no i'm what do
you got to plug
that yeah you can join me
all right yep
keith have like when we first came to
you with this project how did it go
through your mind have you been hearing
about
nfts or was this the first time you got
put on and you started digging in
because i know you're an entrepreneur so
i know this had to hit your level
another show i got a lot of um friends
um that that they've been doing them and
stuff i already posted a couple of my
friends nfts
as you've seen on my instagram like one
called on black pepper i will post a
couple times one of my one of my good
friends out of new york
um but i never just had my own but then
you know because this they came to me
about the book watching their team on
mike
like gary wants you to
do this but right now because you know
i'm saying it's you no i'm saying you
know i said yeah let's do it and try it
out because like i said i don't really
know too much about the nfc i'm still
learning everything how everything goes
i'm really just
a new beginning this [ __ ] so
i already i see where it take me to you
have my own definitely and now that i'm
in on it i definitely want to keep like
going with it you know what i mean like
i alright
here we go interesting that it kind of
caught you now you're like okay i'm
curious let me keep that flow exactly
exactly
right p
oh yeah uh keith would you say that nfts
are pushing p or what
[Music]
what does that mean what does that mean
positivity
greeting p
he's able to push me
anything he's like
like
are we like like uh our career like is
going up this push p like take care of
your family that's pushing p
i'm saying take care of your little ones
if you got something let's push p you've
been a man you're a great woman just put
your people you know he don't stand
you feeling good now you good yeah i'm
good i'm good i'm good good tell
everybody about your music a little bit
like how you came like how you think
about it when you try to push it out um
to be honest i try to make relatable
music
i try to make music about like life
stories that i've been through stuff
that people around me been through that
other people could relate to
real quick i'm gonna take some questions
from the crowd mike while we go around
this is the best one from the silver
brothers gary is this a long-term nft
the reality is i don't know my intuition
is yes because i believe that
these are rookie nft like rookie
collectibles of these incredible mike
how many artists is it 22 22 for 2022.
yeah so
you know
listen it's sports cards are long term
nfts are long term but the people's
faces on it that's up to these three
beautiful faces and the other 19 if if
this the collectible value is based on
the athlete the collectible value in
this series is going to be based on the
artist right so
you know look again i said it earlier
some people were just coming in mike and
i
it's qui you should see mike and ice
mike and i's text red is legendary it's
two in the morning and we're talking and
i'm texting like hey look at this 17
year old kid from jacksonville it's mike
saying to me like yo this kid is in polo
g's crew and i think he's next and we're
just listening to [ __ ] music and
looking at instagram i mean keith you
know this we find people early
people early like we because we're
really putting in the work our
intuition's been really good there's
been plenty of times on the record that
we thought somebody was the next drake
and they're already done with their
music career you just you know there's a
lot of variables that go into this it's
not just the talent it's the mentality
it's also the luck of life sometimes
people have some [ __ ] up [ __ ] to take
them off the tracks so is it a long-term
project
if the artists hit and hit to the next
level we didn't bring anybody here that
is like we're guessing we saw them on
the stream like yeah these are curated
they've already got a wave going on
um but obviously for it to have a
collectible value it's going to require
a lot of demand which means they've got
to get much more popular on the flip
side on the flip side
budweiser who owns this not me
has the ability to do something with
these nfts in the future if they want to
if they wanted to in 25 years different
management team than now say by the way
those those nfts from 2022 that's now a
ticket to a concert we're doing for
emerging artists they could they could
so there's a lot of cool things you can
do with nfts that are different
that's fine
yeah we have face yoda about to join
he's also with ysl young thug's label
but yeah he you should link with beans
she's out in la all the time man
all the time
mike we got six minutes before this
wraps up i know we're waiting for yoda
he may or may not be able to make it in
time anything else that we want to talk
about with these three or maybe we'll
take five minutes and wrap it up
um
i think we should do that because people
have a lot of questions keep being steve
we love you guys we'll see you soon
appreciate appreciate y'all
show a little got it we say hi
dm got it the other day to give him a
little bit yeah i love that
hello gary mike
so look i see the comments we'll see if
if if yoda comes in seth put him on
because i love that kid um if not
another time um
look i think a couple things a lot of
different questions
obviously vayner nft very proud of
working on this me and mike have always
loved you know my entire hip hop life
music life was about unsigned hype i
always loved on side hype mike always
loved finding emerging artists we had
that marriage aj my brother met mike
literally mike what third day sixth day
first day first week i'll never forget
what meaning aj met yeah very early
thursday
so
um you know uh so the reality is is that
um we've been on this wave for a long
time the idea of rookie cards rookie
nfts was very important to me
and really something that i wanted to
think about and um and really focus on
i think that rookie nfts of artists of
all sorts not just athletes is going to
be a real thing however
to address one thing in there i still
have incredible belief that 99 of
projects will fail during this era we're
in a bubble there's too much bad
behavior people are scamming people are
dropping things into people's wallets to
try people to buy them every day on
instagram there's 43 [ __ ] ads being
run claiming i bought something that i
didn't there's a ton of bad behavior
that's always a problem but this is like
internet stocks in 99. there was a ton
of bad behavior then too and everything
collapsed but the internet was here to
stay
nft projects are vulnerable but the nft
macro
ecosystem i think is one of the game
changers in our society
and so a always spend money you can
afford to lose b there's no guarantees
in collectibles and trading c
it'd be a lot better if you buy it
because you believe in some of the
artists even but even not minted and by
its secondary because you'd rather have
this specific artist or d don't buy it
at all but just keep learning but um
it's all really fun the nft thing is fun
i just see um matt come on not matt uh
christopher just say this is confusing
of course it's confusing it's new
technology just like the internet if
you're confused go read as do what i did
back in december 2020 read unlimited
articles listen to unlimited podcasts
listen to
read and watch unlimited videos and
learn learn the 101s of this don't just
jump in here because you see me on this
like be educated before you do [ __ ] be
educated before you do [ __ ]
yeah and join the budweiser discord
we're answering questions all day long
yeah there's a ton going on discord
there is the
the url discord.com
invite slash budweiser
um
mike thank you so much for your
incredible
impact on this project i can't believe
we're on minting day dropping in an hour
really excited about it let's put up the
url to the mint one more time before we
get out of here
um us.budweiser.comft
super excited props to the budweiser
team spencer pedro many others over
there for really trying to make this
consumer-centric and being think of
smart about it and so um
um hopefully uh hopefully uh everybody
has a great day um and most of all buy
with money you can afford
this is all new stuff it's all new
learnings um support things you're
actually passionate about
the people trying to buy things for a
two sec in two days to make a profit
that's all the bad behavior
take a breath go deep learn about this
space there'll be other mints besides
this
um i think this one's fresh but
um really excited about and hope
everybody has a great day we love all of
you we'll see you in an hour in the mint
good luck to get one
and we'll talk soon thanks gary thanks